Orangutans nurse longer than any other mammals.
But figuring out just exactly how long
trying to study these tree-top dwellers.
Now a group of researchers has taken a new approach:
looking for clues about nursing
but in orangutan teeth.
The researchers turned to
for teeth from four wild orangutans
Just as scientists analyze the rings in a tree trunk
for clues about a fallen tree’s life,
the researchers examined teeth
an element that comes from mother’s milk.
Researchers found that
barium deposits varied throughout each year.
An orangutan’s diet consists largely of fruit,
and this yearly fluctuation probably means
when that food source was scarce.
Evidence of nursing continued past eight years,
meaning orangutans are weaned
even later than the researchers had thought.
Scientists hope that learning more
about orangutan behavior in the wild
will aid conservation efforts for these great apes,
whose populations are predicted
to be cut in half in the next decade.